el fondo monetario internacional- mejoró
sus protecciones para este año vamos a
tener más información sobre este tema
aquí con daniela hablando que me
acompaña en el estudio bienvenida a
economía daniela cuéntenos cuáles son
esas proyecciones hola santiago pues
hagamos una claridad y es que esta
organización multilateral hace una
revisión cada tres meses de las
proyecciones así que van cambiando
constantemente desde que inició la
pandemia ha venido actualizando sus
previsiones generalmente al alza en
enero creía que este año la región
crecería 4,1 por ciento después de
haberse contraído en 7% el año pasado y
en su más reciente reporte ubicó la
cifra en 58 % un poco más baja que para
el mundo en general que es del 6% y una
de las razones es la vacunación
la recuperación económica mundial
continúa pero con una brecha cada vez
mayor entre las economías avanzadas y
muchas economías de mercado emergentes y
en desarrollo cerca del 40% de la
población en las economías avanzadas ha
sido completamente vacunado en
comparación con el 11 por ciento en las
economías de mercados emergentes y una
pequeña fracción en los países en
desarrollo de bajos ingresos
bueno daniela también nuevos resultados
el día de hoy de las grandes
tecnológicas buenos resultados muy
buenos resultados de santiago las llame
también llamadas big tex representan o
presentan mejor sus resultados de manera
distinta con años fiscales que comienzan
en diferentes épocas del año sin embargo
el resultado trimestral con corte a
junio frente al mismo período de 2007 es
el más fácil de usar para hacer una
comparación que la vamos a hacer a
continuación miguel este martes
presentaron resultados tres de las más
grandes a por qué duplicó sus beneficios
hasta 21 mil 700 millones de dólares
microsoft lo subió en un 47 por ciento
hasta poco más de 16 mil millones de
dólares
y alphabet que es la matriz de google
ganó más de 18.500 millones en estos
tres meses casi el triple que hace un
año
recordemos que twitter ya había
entregado su reporte hace unos días y
facebook lo va a hacer este miércoles
también con muy buenas perspectivas por
supuesto daniela hablemos ahora de la
industria automotriz algunas de estas
empresas son la mayoría de james están
buscando migrar ya todos sus productos
hacia vehículos eléctricos hay que
empezar a ahorrar para comprarlo así de
santiago pues miren mercedes veces
reveló sus planes de invertir 40 mil
millones de euros en autos con batería
eléctrica en los próximos años pero este
no es el único fabricante que está
planeando un futuro verde veamos el
informe
el deseo de disminuir las emisiones de
dióxido de carbono ha llevado a un
aumento en las ventas de carros
eléctricos en europa y los propietarios
ya están notando la diferencia
lugo es nuevo para mí porque nunca había
tenido un carro de este tipo pero se ha
vuelto parte de mi día a día recorrer
las mismas millas en mi carro antiguo me
costaría alrededor de 150 euros en
gasolina el punto de carga es gratis
pero normalmente la electricidad me
cuesta alrededor de 20 euros al mes
en el segundo trimestre de 2021 los
vehículos eléctricos superaron el doble
de su participación en el mercado
respecto al año pasado con un 7.5 por
ciento este concesionario de automóviles
dice que cada vez más personas hacen el
cambio al comprar su segundo vehículo
kresic tam la gente usará un carro
normal para recorrer largas distancias o
salir de vacaciones pero comprará un
carro eléctrico para ir al trabajo o
realizar tareas del día a día
y pronto quienes viven en europa no
tendrán otra opción la unión europea'
vetar a la venta de carros a gasolina
desde 2035 así lo fábrica
automóviles están contemplando la idea
de los vehículos de batería mercedes
volvo y volkswagen planean volverse a
empresas totalmente eléctricas en el
futuro cercano para acceder y forrest
para volverse eléctricos los fabricantes
tendrán que invertir miles de millones
de euros en tecnología de baterías para
incrementar la duración y reducir el
tiempo de carga pero no todas las
empresas tienen tanto dinero
con las ventas a su favor la industria
automovilística se acerca a un futuro
totalmente eléctrico
ahorrar para el carro eléctrico daniela
vamos con los indicadores pues fue
justamente la expectativa por estos
resultados de los big ticket en la que
hizo que wall street cayera este martes
porque fueron presentados al toque de la
campana en latinoamérica las bolsas se
encerraron mixtos también influenciadas
por resultados empresariales es el caso
de méxico por las ganancias del grupo
méxico y américa móvil cifra del día
para el ser mil 95 millones de dólares
este es el superávit comercial de
méxico- en el primer trimestre de 2021
es decir que las exportaciones superaron
en ese valor a las importaciones y
aumentaron 29%
muchas gracias daniela por esta
actualización del mundo económico sigan
con france24 siga con nuestra
programación
[Música]